really high-end prosthetic and you put
it on eBay and someone bought it like
within a few hours for a thousand
dollars
[Music]
Zach welcome back hey you know good so
this week you've got a story on a guy
who's causing self the flea market
flipper who has found goods and items
online starting with like shoes baby
clothes things like that and has worked
his way up to line two now buying and
flipping construction equipment so tell
us about this guy yeah so it's a couple
robbing Melissa Steffensen out of out of
Florida they basically run this site
called flea market flipper it's a really
cool community they it's kind of an
educational blog where they teach people
and give them the tools of how to how to
flip things and it could be anything
like you said from you know as baby
strollers purses shoes all the way up to
forklifts and you know treadmills I
think Rob was at the point last year
where he's like buying like 40 foot
harley-davidson signs from like
motorcycle dealerships and like shipping
them across the country and selling them
for like 10 grands so you can do with
some really interesting stuff with
flipping but it's kind of kind of this
interesting world and it's it's an
interesting way to make a little side
income that is kind of accessible for
anyone if they have a few tricks that I
can use it's not gonna make you into a
millionaire but you can make a couple
you know I'm 100 bucks here and they're
just off a junkie you have lying around
it adds up I guess it reminds me of so
our founder Sam fire tells the story of
when he was how he got his start as an
entrepreneur when he was like in his
teens and then in high school I remember
him saying like he went on eBay and
Craigslist and sold stuff he he did this
thing where he approached like the
graduating seniors on the baseball team
and he bought their equipment for like
not much money because he knew they
weren't gonna keep playing baseball and
then he sold it on eBay so it's the kind
of thing that I think I just say people
are
any level could do and especially now
more relevant than ever with people
being out work and meeting some side
income yeah and another thing about the
current time we're in is a lot of thrift
shops are still closed so more people
are cleaning out their homes than ever
before right now so you have this like
huge amount of excess stuff that people
are getting rid of but there's nowhere
for it to go so you know I go for a run
every day and I even see it around here
outside of San Francisco there's just a
ton of stuff sitting on the side of the
sidewalk that people are throwing away
because they can't bring it to thrift
stores so you know one one thing that
Rob recommends doing is you know
sometimes there's not a demand for
something locally so people will give
something away for free on Craigslist or
Facebook marketplace and you can take
those things where there's no demand
locally and put them on eBay where
there's a national demand and suddenly
you have a potential pool of 160 million
people to sell something to and there's
always someone out there looking for
something so in our house its baseball
cards and basketball cards and things
like that so Mike yeah are into like
collectibles so I'm sure there's there's
a like a big market for all kinds of
different products and services what's
the craziest thing you heard that he's
flipped let's see there was a he told me
a story about how he flipped a
prosthetic leg
he went to this flea market and this guy
was had found this prosthetic leg at a
state sale and had no idea what it was
was kind of creeped out by and just
wanted to get rid of it so I think he
bought it for like 30 bucks and it turns
out it was like this incredibly fancy
really high-end prosthetic and he put it
on eBay and someone bought it like
within a few hours for a thousand
dollars and then maybe they flipped it
for ten thousand so sure yeah I think it
was worth somewhere around 10 grand so
yeah it's pretty nuts what people find
fascinating well I look forward to
hearing more about it in the sunday
email that's going to come out in a few
days and uh thanks for joining the sack
yeah
[Music]